imagine if there was a supplement a hack
or a strategy that could change
everything for you as a man increased
muscle mass increase energy and focus
burn fat improve mood and even make you
more attractive to the opposite sex
that's the promise of raising
testosterone men around the world are
led to believe that simply increasing
testosterone can solve all of their
problems turning them into physical
specimens with the confidence and
Charisma to match it almost sounds too
good and you know what they say about
things that sound too good
these days it feels like half of Fitness
YouTube is talking about raising
testosterone use this one weird hack to
10 times testosterone and I think it's
largely a waste of time that's maybe a
bit of a bold statement but now I'm
going to break down why I think that
let's start with the obvious raising
testosterone within normal levels within
normal ranges naturally isn't going to
have a huge impact on your life hope
testosterone is measured in nanograms
per deciliter and a normal range is
anywhere between like 300 and 900 say or
a thousand what really matters though is
your free testosterone because most of
the testosterone in your body is bound
to proteins making it unavailable for
use by the body someone taking Peds that
steroids to try and increase their
performance their muscle mass they're
likely to see their nanograms per decily
to go anywhere from two thousand to five
thousand so that's a huge jump
conversely if you're using natural
methods to try and increase your
testosterone within the normal range
then with the best will in the world
with all the optimizations you're likely
to see about a 10 to 20 percent increase
and at the higher end you're likely to
go from 900 to 990 the higher it is then
the more diminishing returns you're
going to experience because if your
body's already producing near its
maximum testosterone it's gonna be
harder to increase it a little bit more
if you look at most of the people who
talk about raising testosterone and you
watch the whole video and take into
account the context normally they will
say at least the reputable ones will say
this isn't going to mean you pack on
loads of muscle overnight you're going
to look at maybe a little bit of extra
muscle a little bit of weight loss
nothing major most likely not going to
make you look like somebody that abuses
steroids that's on Instagram okay it
absolutely won't right what it will do
is is increase some of the it will
mildly increase some of the parameters
that we've talked about related to
testosterone but you know what's not a
waste of time if you want to increase
confidence that's looking after your
skin and maintaining a healthy skin care
regime which is why I'm happy to say
that today's sponsor is tiege Hanley
teach Hanley is a company that
simplifies the process of looking after
your skin by providing not only the
products but simplified steps on how to
use them you don't need to think about
it you just get great skin as long as
you follow the instructions I have
little sunspots and things around my
skin but what I was surprised to see
that was as soon as I started
moisturizing they drastically improved
just because the skin tone around them
is more even and because there's not as
much dead skin and because I have more
color I recommend you start with their
level one system which comes with all
the basics a daily face wash and
exfoliating scrub an AM moisturizer with
SPF 20 and a PM moisturizer and in
addition to amazing skin members of
tiege Hanley also get tons of benefits
including at least 20 of the retail
price access to exclusive monthly deals
the ability to pause or cancel at any
time and free us shipping and you don't
have to take my word for it they have
over 7 000 5 Star reviews so they must
be doing something right because tiege
Hanley is sponsoring today's video
they're offering my viewers a great deal
just click the link in the description
and you'll get 30 off your first box
plus a free gift don't miss out on this
amazing deal click the link and get
started today and now on with the show
even someone using Peds isn't going to
instantly gain tons and tons of muscle
lose loads and loads of fat and unless
they're training and eating right as
well you get people who use steroids who
don't look like they use steroids it's
not an overnight thing you need to put
in the work and that's doubling tripling
quadrupling testosterone levels so if
you're just increasing Yours by a tiny
amount then no you're not going to see a
drastic increase in muscle mass but Adam
you're saying I've seen the studies this
ingredient you know Tonka Ali can
increase testosterone by this amount and
beetroot juice can increase testosterone
by this amount and taking a magnesium
supplement can boost it by this amount
so surely by just stacking these you'll
increase your testosterone by 10 15 20
and before you know it 100 or 200
percent seems logical right well there
are a lot of issues with this firstly we
need to consider that percentages and
points it depends a lot on what your
testosterone is to begin with if you've
got very low testosterone and you add 30
points then that's a bigger relative
increase than if you've got normal
testosterone and you add 30 points at
the same time many of these studies have
been blown way out of proportion for
example most of the studies on Tonka Ali
are based on people with hypogonadism in
other words these are people with
already very low testosterone production
so of course they're going to see a
higher benefit than your me who's got
normal levels of testosterone at the
same time though the body is a complex
self-regulating system it wants to
maintain a state of homeostasis it
doesn't want to suddenly jack up a
certain hormone it is the way it is for
whatever reason you can't just stack
Lots on top of each other and expect to
get additive results it also depends
very much on the mechanisms of action of
that specific herb mineral or
intervention and what your specific
issue might be for example taking extra
magnesium and zinc isn't going to have a
big impact on someone who isn't
deficient in those nutrients to begin
with Tonka Ali is currently the new
hotness when it comes to boosting
testosterone the research surrounding
this one is pretty positive and the
anecdotal evidence is crazy there are
plenty of videos of people exclaiming
that it helped them to regain lost
energy and build more muscle to the
extent that some have even experienced
some of the negative impacts associated
with high tea things like hair loss and
acne
there is a confirmation bias happening
here I'm not saying this doesn't happen
in some cases but again those are likely
people with testosterone levels at the
very lower end of the spectrum and they
are likely unusually strong responders
those with meh experiences tend not to
make videos about their crazy results
with eye-catching thumbnails just take a
look at this poll on Reddit where users
were asked to rate the kind of impact
that the herb had had on them 58 of the
users said the results were good 12
described their experience as Godly
but 62 described it as okay while 38
were meh and 11 were bad and what is
good but not godly I'd suspect that's a
moderate change you know the sort of
change where you're a bit excited for
the first few weeks until you eventually
stop taking the supplement and noticed
no change whatsoever
remember if these interventions are to
be effective they need to be worth doing
forever be honest with me when was the
last time you adopted a testosterone
boosting strategy or even any other
biohack and genuinely stuck with it for
over two years animal studies suggest
that Tonka Ali may work by stimulating
the hypothalamus pituitary adrenal axis
that's the HPA axis and by jacking up
luteinizing hormone and follicle
stimulating hormone and encouraging the
latex cells thereby to get to work and
or it might work by inhibiting sex
hormone binding globulin shbg and thus
increasing free usable testosterone
there's some evidence of it inhibiting
aromatase enzyme to reduce the
conversion of testosterone into estrogen
and it may even have some positive
indirect effects on testosterone simply
by decreasing stress so if you're
someone who has high levels of stress or
someone who has higher levels of sex
hormone binding globulin then you could
see disproportionately positive benefits
from using ta so it is worth trying
these sorts of things out if you have
very low testosterone this is
speculative keep in mind I simply wanted
to demonstrate that just because one
person sees a big effect that doesn't
mean everyone will
those signals then get Amplified and
suddenly everyone is buying this random
herb just like everyone was buying
Tribulus terrestris a while back it's
also not as simple as more testosterone
more muscle as we've already discussed
you also need more free testosterone on
top of that it's about the ratio of
testosterone to other hormones estrogen
dehydrotestosterone and on top of that
you need Androgen receptors in the
muscles in order for the testosterone to
have an effect and cause muscle growth
it's far more nuanced and complex than
most people would have you believe and
we need to treat it as such and of
course another big one is cortisol to
testosterone and what all this means is
that you can have high testosterone but
if your cortisol is high as well then
you might not be as anabolic if both are
at good levels but you don't have as
many Androgen receptors then you might
find you don't build as much muscle mass
the number of Androgen receptors you
have is partly genetic but it can also
be modulated by training which is why
someone who takes steroids isn't
necessarily going to build massive
muscles if they aren't also training
because you need to train to create
those Android this is one reason why
people get different results and
similarly if you have high testosterone
but you also have high estrogen then you
might not get quite the same mood boost
or quite the same aggression as you
otherwise would do from increasing
testosterone likewise there's all this
fuss about icing your balls cold water
exposure as a great way to boost
testosterone but as I explained in my
video on cold showers the studies that
support this are actually focusing on
men who had enlarged blood vessels in
their genital region now this affected
around 10 of the population apparently
if I'm remembering correctly so that's
still a lot of people who might get some
benefit but it's not going to affect
everybody so to say I'm going to take a
cold shower and have this massive
testosterone boost that's just not the
way it's gonna play out at the same time
those days are looking at people in ice
baths usually submerged for a long
period of time not people standing in a
cold shower for one minute in the
morning again we need to consider the
whole context here but what's that once
again I hear you protest but Adam you
say average levels of testosterone have
fallen among the general population men
are losing a percentage of testosterone
every single year we've dropped 10
percent in the last 10 years this is
terrible we need more testosterone but
here's the problem you are not the
average person the average person takes
into account everybody that includes
people who are elderly and we're living
longer than ever before so there's more
of those people in the sample sizes
normally that includes people who are
very overweight and again more people
are overweight than ever before it
includes people who aren't getting
adequate sleep people are very stressed
people eating a poor diet all these
things that we know are more prevalent
today if you're watching this video and
if you watch a lot of videos on boosting
testosterone chances are you go to the
gym eat really well and try and optimize
your sleep which means you do not fall
into that average demographic that
statistic doesn't apply to you you've
already boosted your testosterone back
to the normal level it probably is no
different than it would have been 10
years ago there's not some kind of
conspiracy they're not pumping the air
full of estrogen as much as some people
might like to tell you otherwise so
there's nothing wrong with your
testosterone you don't need this stuff
unless there is something wrong with
your testosterone but because that is
the other side of this
and of course if you do fall into any of
those categories if your sleep is bad or
you don't get any exercise then those
are the things you should be looking at
and not because you need more
testosterone that's missing the forest
for the trees simply because it's the
right thing to do for your health in
general in this case you're not
unhealthy because your testosterone is
low your testosterone is low because
you're unhealthy and you shouldn't
expect some herb to fix all those
problems for you in the place of actual
positive healthy lifestyle changes nor
should you blame your lack of a sex life
on a plastic bottle you've been taking
to work are they absolutely optimal for
your health probably not and sure if you
get a kick out of optimizing every inch
of your lifestyle then go for it but for
most people agonizing over the chemicals
in your shampoo or what fertilizer was
used on the Apple it's just unnecessary
stress basically a waste of time so
again doing all these hacks taking all
these nutrients and supplements isn't
going to suddenly boost your
testosterone levels and help you to
build tons of muscle so you can take
your balls out the freezer but I
actually think that a lot of people
interested in increasing testosterone
and not doing it for the muscle anyways
I might be way off base here but I think
a lot of people are more interested in
becoming Alpha they think that boosting
their testosterone is going to make them
more aggressive assertive confident it's
going to give them loads of energy gonna
make them attack the gym and wake up
first thing in the morning with a raging
hard on ready to Take On The World women
are going to fall at their feet and men
are going to want to be them
unfortunately again that's not how it's
going to play out just as with the
muscle you're not increasing your
testosterone enough here to see any
major differences to your personality
Etc at the same time there's nothing to
say that more testosterone always equals
better mood and a lot of people will
simplify this and tell you that your
depression is probably caused because
you've got low testosterone that's not
true depression is a complex and serious
disorder that has many causes maybe in
some cases it's caused by low
testosterone it can be caused by
neurochemical imbalances it can be
caused by all kinds of things even brain
damage so we can't just say oh this is
going to solve all your problems that's
a little bit callous okay it's quite a
lot callous and all these people telling
you that increasing your testosterone
will suddenly turn you into an alpha
male Giga Chad and once again they're
selling you on a bit of a pipe dream
because think about the last time you
had a higher than normal level of
testosterone chances are that was when
you're a teenager chances are that these
hacks aren't going to get you back to
the state you're in in your late teens
in terms of testosterone production so
how did you feel back then on top of the
world like an absolute boss or we
perhaps shy and awkward and probably
full of mood swings I mean that was my
experience of being a teenager and
probably more confident more focused
more driven now than I was back then I
think that's probably true from those
people here and that's maybe a bit of an
unfair comparison because there's lots
of things going on when you're a
teenager that make you feel a bit
emotionally insecure Etc your brain is
developing your lifestyle is complicated
to say the least but that's kind of my
point I'm saying that there's lots of
things that affect your mood and the way
you feel and just changing this one
thing isn't going to suddenly solve all
your problems unfortunately nothing will
just solve all of your problems likewise
you don't see steroid users suddenly
taking over the world in fact a lot of
them suffer from emotional disorders and
this is because they've jacked their
testosterone up to unnatural levels also
often unintentionally increased estrogen
and to a lesser extent some of these
things are slight concerns if you're
raising testosterone even naturally and
especially with some of these hacks and
herbs and things that you know need
further study perhaps before we've even
addressed the outright negative symptoms
of extremely high testosterone issues
like acne joint pain oily skin hair loss
aggression if your testosterone levels
are normal or high you wouldn't
necessarily want to go above this we
also don't have much research looking at
the long-term impact of something like
Tonka Ali and while there isn't much
strong evidence to suggest short-term
toxicity there are some tenure studies
that do tell us we shouldn't completely
rule it out it's the same reason I don't
recommend the use of synthetic
neurotropics like modafinil the lack of
long-term research just makes it a bad
idea
why waste time and money and even risk
your health when better training and
optimizing your lifestyle will yield far
greater results take the advice of the
Fantastic Josh Brett and make yourself a
late adopter don't buy into the hype of
every new supplement
if you're going to be doing this stuff
safely and properly making sure that
what you're doing is working and
avoiding negative effects and you should
really be doing things like your blood
work and getting the advice of an expert
on top of that but this isn't what most
people are going to do most people are
going to find something that they think
will have an effect and just take it and
hope for the best you need to do your
blood work you need to monitor your
liver enzymes you need to think you need
to be smart about your health point is
it's not that simple and chances are
that this 10 increase in testosterone
isn't going to suddenly change your life
and I am someone who did a lot of this
stuff because I'm the Pioneer I'm
interested in this stuff I did lots of
biohacks as a younger guy to try and
increase testosterone I took all sorts
of supplements that were all the rage at
the time Tribulus terrestris which now
is considered to be absolutely nothing
trust me a lot of the supplements that
we're using now are going to be just
ignored in a few years as well none of
it made a lick of difference to the way
I felt
physically I didn't feel a difference
taking these supplements like I didn't
feel like I had more performance in the
gym I didn't feel more virile for life I
didn't feel much of a difference because
I already had great lifestyle habits I I
realized recently I feel like it kind of
loses its effect and then I feel like
when you cycle off and then go back on
it it seems to bump it back up again
so for this video I did decide to order
some Tom Cat alley and give it a go and
it's only been just over a week but many
people who find they have results say it
after about six days
I'm not lying when I say I feel
absolutely nothing I haven't got any
increased energy never increased libido
no increased muscle mass or leanness
just you know normal plain old me and
I'm not saying that all those people
that say they get these results are
lying I'm not saying that can't happen
as I've explained they have different
processes that can affect different
people differently and you're more
likely to experience something if you
have low testosterone all I'm saying is
that this experience my experience is
also very common and probably I would
wager by far the more common one what
has made a massive difference in terms
of my energy and focus and drive is
training throughout the day something
I've talked about loads on this channel
splitting my workouts up throughout the
day has practically solved any brain fog
any lethargy that I might have had I
have far more energy and I'm spiking my
protein synthesis multiple times
throughout the day so that to me is by
far a much better life hack so maybe
give that a try and to be clear I'm not
saying that this stuff can't work that
you won't get any benefit I'm saying
that the benefit will be small it will
be a tiny bit and that could be
beneficial for some people if you're
someone with very low test testosterone
then chances are that something like
this could be useful for you if you're
in the 300 range or even lower if you're
suffering things like depression and
erectile dysfunction and you can't gain
muscle and you keep gaining weight you
may well have low testosterone and
something like tomcatally could be a
great alternative before you consider
hormone replacement therapy I'd still
recommend seeing a doctor and speaking
to them because that's an actual
condition but the majority of people
watching this day for the 99.9 all the
effort in the world is likely to
increase your testosterone by a very
small margin and you almost certainly
won't feel it and the best hacks for
increasing testosterone are training and
working out losing weight getting better
sleep getting outdoors more these things
will do wonders for your testosterone
compared with you know some herb or
nutrient or whatever and you don't need
to think about it because it just is
stuff you should be doing anyways so you
just don't put too much focus on
testosterone don't waste too much time
or money on it unless you're someone who
has an actual condition that's why I
wanted to make this video because I
think the amount of discussion
surrounding testosterone is extremely
dis proportionate to the amount of
benefit that it can get you I'm sure
there's lots of you who disagree with me
of course that's absolutely fine and if
you're someone who's had a big benefit
from doing any of that stuff and
focusing on their testosterone that's
absolutely awesome
um me personally I've stopped thinking
about it other than all the videos that
pop up on my feed let's start a
discussion down below let me know what's
worked for you let me know what you
focus on instead of testosterone and
whether you agree with me broadly either
way thank you so much for watching this
one guys and I'll see you next time bye
for now